im april hat das
bundesverfassungsgericht ein
historisches urteil gefällt das deutsche
klimaschutzgesetz ist in teilen
verfassungswidrig und geht es um unsere
generation um unser regel keine
begründung des urteils heißt es
sinngemäß dass details noch sehr jungen
kläger durch die bestimmungen im gesetz
in ihren freiheitsrechten verletzt
werden deutschland muss also
nachjustieren teil des neuen
klimaschutzprogramms 2030 sind weiterhin
der ausbau erneuerbarer energien mehr
elektro ladesäulen effizientere gebäude
aber ganz zentral auch die einführung
einer nationalen co2 bepreisung denn
viele forschende und menschen in der
politik sind sich einig die erderwärmung
anzufeuern muss in zukunft kosten und
klimafreundliche alternativen müssen
günstiger werden
aber ob das alles wirklich was bringt
welches system das beste ist was das mit
dem benzinpreis macht und wie das alles
sozial gerecht geht das nehmen wir heute
mal genauer unter die lupe
wir haben in den letzten jahren vieles
angestoßen im bereich des klimaschutzes
manches
um später vielleicht auf zu spielen das
war sehr stark heute tut oder nicht tut
das kann in grundrechte von künftigen
generationen eingreifen wenn es um
klimaschutz geht gibt es einen begriff
der immer wieder fällt klimaneutral
klima oder auch co2 neutralität ist das
non plus ultra das höchste ziel dass zum
beispiel auch die europäische union
erreichen möchte
spätestens bis 2050 deutschland
inzwischen sogar bis 2045 dabei heißt
neutral aber natürlich nicht dass wir
mit den emissionen wirklich auf null
kommen denn 0 gibt es in dem sinne
eigentlich gar nicht das allermeiste was
du machst ist oder kauft produziert
irgendwo emissionen co2 neutralität kann
man also eigentlich nur auf zwei arten
erreichen einerseits wirklich alle
emissionen und komplett stoppen also
quasi aufhören zu existieren oder etwas
realistischer die zweite option
emissionen so gut es geht verringern und
parallel den rest durch negative
emissionen ausgleichen
viele länder peilen das bis mitte des
jahrhunderts an aber ihr könnt das auf
einem persönlichen level schon heute
erreichen und zwar mit der app klima im
sponsor dieses videos hier und wie das
genau funktioniert dazu kommen wir
später aber wie kommt man denn überhaupt
dahin alle zum sparen von emissionen zu
bringen wie reguliert man eine industrie
die fleisch produziert dinge
transportiert kleidung herstellt und
alle möglichen anderen kleinen dinge
macht die eben alle co2 verursachen und
das am besten auch noch alles fair und
ohne dass ich irgendeine branche heraus
redet oder wieder sonderregeln bekommt
genau das ist das ziel der co2
bepreisung emittenten blechen für jede
tonne ausgestoßenes co2 und werden so
ermutigt die nächste tonne lieber zu
sparen
und hier gibt es vor allem zwei
möglichkeiten wie man das genau macht
die co2 steuer und der sogenannte
emissionshandel fangen wir erstmal mit
dem emissionshandel an denn den gibt es
auf eu ebene tatsächlich schon seit 2005
denn wenn wir erst einmal verstanden
haben wie das aktuelle system
funktioniert wird auch klar warum das
bisher leider noch nicht so richtig
geklappt hat
die grundidee des emissionshandels ist
das zum beispiel die eu jedes jahr ein
co2 maximum festlegt dass insgesamt in
der luft landen darf
unternehmen die eine bestimmte menge
treibhausgase ausstoßen möchten müssen
dafür zertifikate erwerben
diese ausstoß berechtigungen werden
nicht nur am markt verkauft sondern
werden vor allem auch untereinander
gehandelt und weiterverkauft sowie
aktien quasi wenn also eine fabrik
weniger co2 ausstößt als sie vorher
berechnet hat kann sie die übrigen
zertifikate an andere fabriken verkaufen
und damit geld verdienen nachhaltiges
handeln wird also belohnt
die kosten für ein zertifikat werden so
durch normale marktmechanismen
beeinflusst die weniger zertifikate da
sind desto teurer wird es den
klimawandel weiter zu befeuern
also das gute alte angebot und nachfrage
und mit jedem jahr wird der co2 deckel
also die gesamtmenge an co2 ausgestoßen
werden darf weiter gesenkt was den druck
zusätzlich erhöht den eigenen ausstoß zu
verringern
deswegen nennt sich dieses system auch
cap and trade begrenzungen und handel
ihr seht das ist eigentlich ein ziemlich
elegantes system
zwar ist diese handel am anfang recht
aufwändig einzurichten aber wenn er
läuft dann läuft er und reguliert sich
quasi von selbst und es können sogar
eben ohne einfluss von außen sehr
spannende effekte entstehen wie zum
beispiel dass die emissionen als erstes
dort eingespart werden wo es am
einfachsten und damit am günstigsten
umzusetzen ist dass mich das am besten
mal mit dem beispiel erklären
nehmen wir mal an die lufthansa und die
deutsche bahn würden beide beim
emissionshandel mitmachen tut die beiden
jetzt nicht aber okay beide kaufen ihre
zertifikate
während flugzeuge so schnell
wahrscheinlich nicht ohne kerosin
auskommen werden könnte die bahn schon
heute auf mehr grünen strom setzen
die bahn könnte also vergleichsweise
einfach co2 einsparen und zum beispiel
der lufthansa ein paar ihrer zertifikate
verkaufen
so haben sie direkt ein doppeltes
wirtschaftliches interesse daran dass
co2 zu reduzieren
einmal weil sie weniger für zertifikate
ausgeben müssen und dann noch einmal
weil sie mit zusätzlichen einsparungen
sogar geld verdienen können
das heißt auch wenn ein konzern wie die
lufthansa erst mal wenig co2 einsparen
wird gleichen das andere konzerne im
idealfall automatisch aus dadurch sollen
die emissionen insgesamt trotzdem sinken
und der markt reguliert ja die preise in
unserem beispiel sollte also fliegen mit
der zeit immer teurer und bahn fahren
immer günstiger werden
das heißt natürlich nicht dass die
lufthansa nicht auch maßnahmen ergreifen
könnte und teilweise schon ergreift um
ihren fußabdruck zu verringern
neben alternativen treibstoffen könnte
einem konzern für die lufthansa ja zum
beispiel auch in carbon capture methoden
investieren
die holen bereits ausgestoßene co2
wieder aus der atmosphäre und sorgen so
für die negative emissionen von dem ich
ja eben schon mal gesprochen hatte bis
zum breitflächigen einsatz muss hier
allerdings noch sehr viel geforscht
werden
aber eben solche forschungen könnte
durch dieses geld ja auch vorangebracht
werden okay aber genug von der lufthansa
die ist ja auch nur ein beispiel für
einen konzern der bereits am
emissionshandel teilnimmt die deutsche
bahn zum beispiel tut das leider nicht
und hier sind wir bei einem großen
problem des bisherigen emissionshandels
bisher sind hier in der mich vor allem
die stromproduktion die industrie und
teile der luftfahrt inbegriffen wodurch
etwa nur die hälfte der emissionen in
der eu abgedeckt werden
kein schlechter anfang sagen die einen
aber auch die wärmeversorgung die
gebäudewirtschaft und eben der verkehr
sind offensichtlich große quellen von
co2 auch bereiche wie die landwirtschaft
bleiben aktuell mehr oder weniger
unangetastet weil die meisten anderen
treibhausgase zum beispiel methan aus
vier haltung oder anbau nicht durch
zertifikate geregelt sind
dabei hat methan eine bis zu 28 mal
hören treibhauseffekt als co2 den umgang
mit vielen dieser anderen treibhausgase
erinnert das neue klima paket der
bundesregierung leider auch nicht aber
zumindest werden die bereiche verkehr
und gebäude 2021 teil des nationalen
emissionshandels und zudem kommen wir
gleich noch der zweite große grund warum
das system bisher leider nicht sein
volles potenzial ausschöpfen konnte
durch die wirtschaftskrise 2008 2009
aber auch weil am anfang zertifikate
einfach kostenlos verteilt wurden konnte
der preis über jahre hinweg da nicht
richtig steigen
aber auch hier gibt es gute nachrichten
seit 2018 steigt der preis deutlich und
aktuell kostet ein zertifikat über 50
euro pro tonne co2
und damit sind wir inzwischen
tatsächlich in einem bereich der wirkung
zeigen könnte aber reicht das
hier kommt die co2 steuer ins spiel
vorweg direkt entwarnung die co2 steuer
ist deutlich simpler als der
emissionshandel und das ist etwas gutes
ähnlich wie bei einer mehrwertsteuer
wird hier einfach ein bestimmter
steuersatz auf jede tonne co2 festgelegt
anders als die mehrwertsteuer wird die
co2 steuer aber nicht erst am ende auf
ein produkt drauf gerechnet sondern
schon am anfang auf die verwendeten
energieträger wie öl gas oder kohle und
zwar je nachdem wie viel
kohlenstoffdioxid sie jeweils freisetzen
und dieser unterschied ist ganz wichtig
ein mythos der co2 steuer ist nämlich
dass sie von uns privatpersonen direkt
bezahlt wird und wir unseren
persönlichen co2 verbraucht zum beispiel
in der steuererklärung auch führen
müssten
stimmt natürlich überhaupt nicht die
mehrkosten entstehen auch hier vor allem
in den kraftwerken oder
produktionsstätten sobald dort rohstoffe
eingekauft werden
dabei wäre die steuer im vergleich zum
emissionshandel auch viel
unkomplizierter einzurichten und auch
besser planbar weil der kostenaufschlag
sich nicht ständig verändert sondern
wenn dann kontrolliert erhöht wird
ok klingt ja erst mal so als wäre die
steuer das deutlich bessere modell oder
na ja nicht unbedingt auch wenn eine
steuer einfacher startet entsteht der
aufwand dann nach hinten raus denn
einmal festgelegt muss natürlich die
wirksamkeit der steuer überprüft werden
die steuer muss regelmäßig angepasst
wieder überprüft und sowieso wie jede
steuer mit viel bürokratischem aufwand
auch eingefordert verrechnet und nach
gehalten werden
aber das viel größere problem mit der
besteuerung von treibhausgasen ist dass
es hier keinen deckel gibt also die
gesamtmenge des co2 theoretisch
unbegrenzt ist während es beim
emissionshandel irgendwann einfach keine
zertifikate mehr gibt um noch mehr
auszustoßen können sich bei einer co2
steuer unternehmen mit viel geld einfach
freikaufen und unverändert die luft
verschmutzen
letztendlich bedeutet die besteuerung ja
auch nur dass die produktionskosten
steigen und unternehmen für ihre
produkte am ende einfach einen höheren
preis verlangen
und das bringt uns zu einem sehr
wichtigen punkt nämlich der sozialen
gerechtigkeit denn egal für welches
system wir uns entscheiden co2 steuer
emissionshandel oder vielleicht sogar
eine mischung aus beidem
die kosten werden im zweifel am ende
wieder auf uns verbraucher abgewälzt
wenn rohstoffe teurer werden werden auch
die fertigen produkte teurer vom strom
aus der steckdose bis hin zu
lebensmitteln damit darunter nicht
insbesondere einkommensschwache personen
leiden müssen wir über ein drittes und
letztes instrument sprechen und zwar die
klima dividende die klima dividende ist
ein weg wie man die co2 steuer aber auch
den emissionshandel sozial gerecht
gestalten kann und das ist super wichtig
hier kommt das gesamte geld das durch
co2 abgaben zusammenkommt in einem topf
der am ende wieder gleichmäßig auf alle
bürger aufgeteilt wird
wenn man mit seinem persönlichen
fußabdruck genau im durchschnitt liegt
und in deutschland aktuell um die zehn
tonnen pro jahr
dann bekommt man mit dieser prämie genau
das zurück was man vorher für den
eigenen konsum drauf gezahlt hat wenn
man aber weniger co2 verursacht als der
durchschnitt dann bekommt man mit
derselben premier am ende eben mehr
zurück als man ursprünglich ausgegeben
hat einkommensschwache personen haben in
der regel auch einen sparsameren
lebensstil fahren weniger auto und
verreisen weniger sie würden deswegen am
ende belohnt werden während
wohlhabendere menschen ganz nach dem
verursacherprinzip tendenziell - machen
würden weil sie eben auch tendenziell
mehr verbrauchen und das beste von
alledem wenn durch diesen doppelten
hebel alle menschen dazu veranlasst
werden weniger co2 zu verursachen
dann sind natürlich auch der
durchschnitt
ein funktionierendes modell der klima
dividende gibt es zum beispiel bereits
in der schweiz
hier werden seit 2008 zwei drittel der
einnahmen ausgeschüttet und das letzte
drittel geht in die direkte förderung
von umweltprojekten und jetzt wird
endlich auch in deutschland ein solches
system gesprochen während die klima
dividende vor ein paar jahren immer
wieder ein streitpunkt war taucht sie
heute in den wahlprogrammen von den
grünen der spd und sogar der fdp auf die
werden häufig nicht dividende genannt
weil das geld in eigentlich allen
entwürfen erstmal dazu genutzt werden
soll die eeg umlage zu reduzieren
ähnlich wie in der schweiz würde hier
also erst einmal geld in die direkte
finanzierung der energiewende fließen
während parallel die basis für eine
tatsächliche ausschüttung pro kopf
geschaffen wird
aber egal ob man es jetzt klima
dividende oder bürgergeld oder pro kopf
bonus nennt die stimmen dafür werden
immer lauter
was aber jetzt schon realität ist
zumindest seit diesem jahr ist der
nationale emissionshandel kurze
wiederholung ein emissionshandel ist
relativ aufwendig einzurichten und gibt
nicht ganz so viel planungssicherheit
dafür reguliert er sich aber selbst gibt
ein festes co2 budget vor und garantiert
eine tatsächliche einsparung der
treibhausgase die co2 steuer ist ein
festpreis und dadurch simpler und
überschaubarer muss allerdings dauerhaft
überwacht und angepasst werden auch über
politische und wirtschaftliche
veränderungen wie zum beispiel inflation
hinweg außerdem ist hier der effekt der
einsparung nicht garantiert interessant
am neuen nationalen emissionshandel in
deutschland ist hier werden diese beiden
modelle mehr oder weniger miteinander
verbunden und zwar mit all ihren vor und
nachteilen bis 2025 ist nämlich noch ein
festpreis pro tonne co2 vorgesehen den
jedes jahr erhöht wird
das ist eher wie eine steuer die
zertifikate werden hier verkauft nicht
versteigert ab 2026 gehen wir dann in
einen tatsächlichen handel über erst
noch in einem preiskorridor und ab 2027
kann sich der preis dann komplett frei
entwickeln was das dann genau für den
preis ab 2027 bedeutet also wie stark
der vielleicht sprungartig nach oben
steigt das wird sich noch zeigen
ein vorteil der fixen co2 preise ist
dass man die auswirkungen auf bestimmte
produkte bereits absehen kann
so steht zum beispiel bereits jetzt fest
dass der liter benzin bis 2025 um 15,5
cent teurer wird warum ich das so genau
erzählen ja weil die grünen gerade total
ins kreuzfeuer geraten weil sie eine
verteuerung von sprit fordern
und hier ist die rede von 16 cent bis
2023 also ein sehr ähnlicher preis an
sprung wir sowieso kommen wird und zwar
nicht durch die grünen sondern durch ein
system das die aktuelle große koalition
auf den weg gebracht hat von dieser
wahlkampf schlammschlacht die gerade
abgeht mal komplett abgesehen finde ich
es schwierig mir jetzt schon eine
meinung zum nationalen emissionshandel
zu bilden klar ist dass die regierung
mit den festpreisen versucht einen
besonders guten übergang in ein
handelssystem zu garantieren und die
wirtschaft möglichst wenig zu belasten
hoffentlich für das aber auch nicht dazu
dass während dieser übergangszeit also
die nächsten sechs jahre einfach nichts
passiert weil zu wenig druck da ist denn
so viel zeit haben wir leider nicht aber
während sich all das erst in den
nächsten jahren klären wird kannst du
tatsächlich jetzt schon etwas für deine
ganz persönliche klima ausgleich tun und
zwar mit der app klima mit klima könnt
ihr euch anhand einfacher fragen zu
ihrem lebensstil ihren ganz persönlichen
co2 fußabdruck berechnen lassen wie
gesagt in deutschland liegt er aktuell
bei ungefähr zehn tonnen co2 pro kopf
und ich finds persönlich mega spannend
sich mal anzuschauen wie man da so im
vergleich abschneidet die crux bei klima
ist jetzt aber du hast dann die
möglichkeit diesen fußabdruck direkt aus
der app heraus zu oft hätten also
auszugleichen
dafür berechnet ihr die app einen ganz
individuellen monatlichen beitrag quasi
deine persönliche co2 steuer mit der du
dann eins oder mehrere ausgewählte
umwelt projekte finanzieren kannst von
deinen beiträgen fließend 70 direkt in
die projekte zehn prozent in die
entwicklung und den betrieb der app und
die verbleibenden 20 prozent finanzieren
das marketing also zum beispiel auch
dieses video hier das von klima
gesponsert wurde
die projekte binden oder reduzieren dann
für dich co2 etwa durch aufforstung
wodurch den co2 fußabdruck neutralisiert
wird und es kostet im durchschnitt
weniger als zehn euro im monat und ich
hab das jetzt auch gemacht und bin habe
ich persönlich zahle 11 eur 55 weil ich
tatsächlich noch ein bisschen mehr
unterwegs bin das meiste geht bei mir
für mobility drauf aber elf auf 550
monatlich tatsächlich ziemlich wenig
dafür dass ich jetzt einen super
gewissen haben kann weil ich den
klimawandel nicht mehr weiter befeuert
zusätzlich und top gibt es dann auch
noch gute tipps um klimafreundlicher zu
leben und mehr zu den gesamten projekten
die klima unterstützt sowie alle
weiteren informationen zur app findet
ihr natürlich auf der website klima
punkt kommen und mit dem link unten in
der video beschreibung kommt ihr direkt
zur app und wenn euch dort anmeldet
unterstütze auch gleichzeitig noch uns
und unsere videoproduktion
vielen dank dafür und an dieser stelle
auch vielen lieben dank an klaus vom
kanal zu der unsere reaktion bei diesem
sehr komplexen thema unterstützt und
beraten hat wenn euch diese themen hier
interessieren dann schaut auf jeden fall
mal bei ihm auf youtube vorbei er macht
wirklich sehr geile hochqualitative
videos zu allen möglichen klimathemen
und ansonsten wie immer auch vielen dank
an euch danke fürs zuschauen und bleibt
neugierig